and you know starts off this hour in
Greenville North Carolina hi Aniyah how
are you come day-long any days better
than I deserve what's up in your world
awesome well I just want to ask you a
question um I got a little bit of
trouble and I got a DUI and I lost my
license for a year yeah I made a mistake
but on the bright side I learned from it
so looks all the better
however the question I had was regarding
my car I had a paid off car and because
I lost my license for a year I can't
drive um so I was wondering what I
should do with my car do you before to
sell it and just stop my insurance and
all that extra that comes with the car
or should I just um keep it in a storage
for a year to two years
what is the car worth oh I looked at
Kelley Blue Book and the best that could
have gotten would be under thirteen
thousand um and I got an offer for it
for ten thousand like seven hundred
fifty dollars for her it's one of the
chevrolet dealership okay so they're
offering you wholesale and the the
retail value if you were to sell it on
Craigslist to an individual's more like
thirteen thousand right but i had
originally bought the car for 16 plus
all that extra fees on top of it i would
definitely be losing money either way
with our with the personal um it's just
a matter of how much you would be leeway
you've already lost the money the car's
value is 13 and cars all go down in
value so we all lose money on cars so
what is your household income
well almost do it right now so i get i'm
using the GI Bill so I get about um
about thirteen hundred a month that's
your stipend right right and then their
prom then they're also paying for your
tuition right correct and my book okay
very cool very cool here are you I am a
sophomore at East Carolina University
good what are you studying I'm studying
business
I haven't yet chosen a specialty I'm
just doing the basic business classes
for right now and that's your full-time
gig right now right I'm taking 16
credits Oh
are you working at all uh not yet I was
gonna I took a break from my waitressing
job to see how the first couple of weeks
of school were going to be okay alright
so you had been waitressing before how
are you getting around now that your
normal license well you need to like a
bus system that takes me to and from
school and it's come every 15 minutes
and it's Monday through Friday and then
Thursday Friday and Saturdays they take
you to and from downtown like nighttime
and is that where you're waitressing or
well I'm wasting it
back home not 45 minutes or so away but
I took a break from there yeah but you
ain't got a way to run back and forth
there you have to do find a job around
town alright crowd we have to try to
walk through the whole picture of what
you're facing okay yes I would sell the
car no I would not sell it to the dealer
okay and here's what I would you have
any debt no debt free good for you good
for you yes I would sell it I did here
Financial Peace University class and I
was able to pay off my debt Thanks here
good for you well you did it um but here
I want to sell it for thirteen thousand
I don't want to sell it for ten thousand
I want to set the thirteen thousand in
the bank and don't touch it for anything
period ever okay because you're going to
use it to buy under the car when you get
your license back and get out of school
which is going to be about the same time
give or take all right here's the reason
I'm doing that mathematically that
thirteen thousand dollar car a year from
now will be worth what ten thousand
right it's going to continue to go down
in value plus you will have paid
the insurance on it during that time and
if there's any taxes in your area on a
car you will have paid that during that
time and so you will have lost three or
four thousand dollars while you're in
college during this coming year on that
vehicle that you can't drive and so I'd
rather just let the money sit there and
then go buy another car with that money
and you'll have thirteen thousand versus
a year from now you'll be less the
insurance money and have a car that is
worth less money that you got no use of
during that year does that make sense
involved but selling it for ten thousand
does not make sense my parents think I
should keep it because car is going to
get more and more expensive as a time
goes by um not that one not that one
that one's going to get less expensive
you could listen you could buy it you
can put your 13,000 in the bank and turn
around and buy that same car next year
for ten thousand bucks
okay so I mean that that's the thing
because the car is going the wrong way
in value and so and you might you might
choose to buy a better car for thirteen
thousand you should be able to a newer
car then that one is because next year
that car will only be worth X number of
dollars thirteen might not be right it
might be eleven it might be nine but if
the point is it will go down in value
while it's sitting in your driveway and
and you will write a check for how much
is your insurance a year oh well it was
all about five hundred and sixty um but
since this incident VI I'm not sure how
much it would cost to keep the insurer
oh yeah and you got to keep insurance on
somebody steals the car
you lose thirteen thousand dollars right
and so you have to you know you it's
just if you're going to lose three four
thousand bucks by holding on to it but
don't lose it by selling it to the
dealer we're not desperate here we're
just trying to be wise so just take good
solid slow steps if you can get around
twelve five to thirteen five for that
car I would sell it put the money in the
bank park it then go buy another car
next year
you'll end up with a better car or the
same car for less money and you'll end
up with money in your pocket by having
done that if you keep your hands off the
stinking money and the good news is
you've learned a really really expensive
lesson here and a really painful lesson
and hopefully that's helped you redirect
your life right it has definitely on and
plus I don't believe her so it
definitely helps that I rely on I've now
more than I've ever done so in my life I
feel like it's a little bit of an
eye-opener and a test fit to my face
yeah I've done a lot of stupid things
and when life's max a crud out of you
following stupidity it helps you're a
Josh doesn't it I know how you feel
kiddo
well you keep turning it around we're
proud of you for turning it around and
that's exactly what I would do I would
get it sold but don't don't give it away
don't wholesale the car out you want to
get good money for it and that's how I
did the analysis I'll walk through it
with you it does make sense but it's an
interesting interesting question I don't
know if I'll have that one certainly
haven't it lately good question thanks
for calling hey guys Rachael Cruz here
hope you enjoyed that video from the
Dave Ramsey show if you want to watch
another great video check out my video
three things you should consider renting
right over here or click the link in the
description below